It's official: The folks at Dunder Mifflin
are moving out.
As hard as it is to hear, the beloved sitcom
The Office is leaving Netflix.
The streaming giant confirmed the news on
Tuesday, June 25th, tweeting that The Office
will remain in its content library until January
2021.
Then, it's gone from Netflix for good.
"Why am I so sad?
Am I doing the wrong thing?
Absolutely not.
It's just that sometimes, goodbyes are a bitch."
Before you start sobbing into your "World's
Best Boss" mugs, you should know that it's
not all bad.
Viewers who fell in love with The Office can
still binge the series from the comfort of
their own homes.
They'll just have to do it on a different
streaming platform.
Starting in 2021, The Office will be available
to watch on NBCUniversal's yet-to-release
streaming service.
The Office's quirky cast of characters and
its witty storylines have found a place in
millions of viewers' hearts over the years.
In 2018, Netflix subscribers spent more time
watching The Office than any other television
series available to stream on the platform,
so as hard as the show's departure will be
for viewers, it may be even harder for Netflix.
"That's what she said!”
The reason why The Office is leaving Netflix
is because NBCUniversal, which owns the series,
has decided to remove it from the steaming
platform and bring it to its own service.
NBCUniversal previously licensed The Office
to Netflix, but now that the series' current
deal with the service is about to expire and
NBCUniversal's yet-unnamed platform is expected
to launch in the middle of 2020, it isn't
advantageous for NBCUniversal to continue
granting streaming rights to Netflix.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, the company
has secured exclusive domestic streaming rights
for all nine seasons of The Office in a five-year
deal, paying a staggering $100 million per
year to stream it on its upcoming platform.
"Man, that is a lot of guacamole.
Lot of the green.
Lot of green."
NBCUniversal executives are incredibly excited
that The Office is shifting from Netflix to
the impending streaming service, with the
company's chairman of direct-to-consumer and
digital enterprises Bonnie Hammer saying,
"The Office has become a staple of pop-culture
and is a rare gem whose relevance continues
to grow at a time when fans have more entertainment
choices than ever before.
We can't wait to welcome the gang from Dunder
Mifflin to NBCUniversal's new streaming service."
When Netflix addressed the situation, it took
a slight jab at NBCUniversal in mentioning
that Office fans can continue watching the
series ad-free until January 2021.
By contrast, NBCUniversal's streaming service
is "ad-supported."
The move to have The Office leave Netflix
has been in progress for some time now.
In April 2019, it was reported that NBCUniversal
brass were engaging in, quote, "internal discussions
about removing The Office from Netflix when
the contract expires in 2021" and subsequently
loading it onto the new streaming site.
This is exactly what happened with Friends,
another much-adored sitcom that originally
aired on NBC.
Warner Bros.
Television produced and distributed Friends,
and Netflix paid a pretty penny to keep the
series in its library year after year.
Though it was briefly believed at the end
of 2018 that Friends would leave the platform
in January 2019, the truth is that it's sticking
around until sometime in 2020, when WarnerMedia's
new streaming site enters the arena.
WarnerMedia intends to use Friends as a major
selling point for the new platform, and it's
likely that NBCUniversal wants to do the same
with The Office.
With The Office and so many other wonderful
shows getting plucked from Netflix, the platform
is going to have to ramp up its original content
to keep subscribers around.
Netflix has great original series like Stranger
Things, BoJack Horseman, GLOW, The Crown,
and more in its catalogue - but it remains
to be seen whether those shows will ever be
able to fill the void The Office will leave
behind.
All we can do for now is enjoy it while it's
here, and remember what a wise man once said:
"WHERE ARE THE TURTLES?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.